oh this is smoking
oh god i feel like this has to work
it's not a disaster yet no is the
toaster the thing that gets me
[Music]
welcome back to chef out of water i'm
alexis the chef who's always up for a
challenge i've taken to the internet to
ask you what appliance i should make a
three-course meal with i'll be tasting
everything myself
so
hopefully it goes well let's see what
you guys have chosen this time
[Music]
ah
toaster you know i always knew this
could be a possibility but um i kind of
blocked it out what is this
a toaster baggie is this a thing you put
things in the toaster bag is this safe
i've never seen this before listen the
good news is there's four sloths so
things can happen kind of at the same
time the bad news is it's a toaster
i don't feel great about this
wish me luck toasters obviously used to
make toast but in this research i'm not
finding that like people are cooking a
lot of things there's the two settings
and i can do different temperatures
fabulous it doesn't feel like
they get really hot okay good to know
these look like they don't melt
you can't put liquid in it so i'm not
sure how useful this actually is to me
my confidence level right now
is that a seven i'm actually really
surprised at how hot it gets i think i'm
gonna be okay fingers crossed
i'm feeling pretty apprehensive about
how well the toaster is going to work
but i have made a plan i'm going to
start with dessert like i usually do and
i'm going to try to make elephant ears
or
palmiers they're like puff pastry
spirals with cinnamon and sugar you can
make them sweet or savory but i'm going
to opt for sweet to get started i just
need to roll out my puff pastry and i'm
just going to trim it nice
so i'm going to use cinnamon sugar for
the filling
and i'm going to sprinkle cinnamon on
both sides do you want to be pretty
generous with this
and you just want to roll both sides up
so that kind of like curls like an
elephant ear
just trim the sides off
i'm gonna let these chill for a bit so
that they're a little more stable before
i pop them in the tester and i don't
really have a backup plan but i'll deal
with that later moving on to my next
course
[Music]
next up i'm going to work on my
appetizer i'm going to make potato chips
and like a smoked fish dip but first i'm
going to focus on the chips which i'm
going to try to fry
in the toaster i'm trying to keep the
chips all pretty uniform thin
i'm just gonna add some olive oil maybe
i should start with like one chip in a
bag speaking of inefficiency this is
gonna be very painstaking
high heat let's see how that goes i'll
try another one with like
a few potatoes in it just to see if they
can cook at the same time and on this
one i'll try a lower heat as i'm saying
it i feel like that's a bad choice
maybe this on fourth
this feels strange
okay so this potato just ripped and is
cooking far from crispy but
let's pop it back in
it smells vaguely
burnt
okay this potato is broken but you can
see it's starting to get a little brown
they're kind of whizzing they kind of
sound like they've been on a sheet pan
in the oven
this kind of smells burning so
oh god
the outside looks like it's getting
cooked and a bit burnt the inside
you just touch it
still
not crisp my confidence level
is a four
while those potatoes are going i'm gonna
soak some wooden skewers and some water
to get ready for my next course whenever
you're using wooden skewers whether it's
on the grill in the oven
in the toaster you want to make sure
that you've soaked them with water first
oh this is smoking oh god okay
[Music]
it appears that my chip is fully burnt
this chip looks good
it looks fine
it doesn't look great
add a little salt
oh god
so for the dip i'm just gonna make a
smoked fish dip got some creme fraiche
lemon zest gonna add a little lemon
juice and you can kind of just like
flake it right off
yum and some dill salt
a little pepper
so pretty listen if the chips are fail
the dip which had nothing to do with the
toaster
is a success appetizer is done
[Music]
oh i am not feeling good about this i
have my frozen elephant ears and i just
need to slice them
okay little elephant ear let's hope for
the best
just a lot of waiting with appliances
like this
does look like it's starting to puff a
tiny tiny bit look at the edge there
maybe if it's just in
like one flat square it has a better
chance of puffing i don't really know
what dessert this is just a
puff pastry square
oh shoot this is burning as i suspected
the outside is burnt the inside is still
raw i just i don't have a backup plan
i've never not completed it
guys this is
it's not going well
these are burnt too
the puff pastry square also doesn't work
is the toaster the thing that gets me
i'm gonna do a little more research you
know the toaster it is giving off a lot
of heat inside so i kind of think if i
put something on top of it and use it
more like a stovetop or something a
little more conventional
i might be more successful
i hope
feeling
a tiny bit more optimistic than i was
before i've got a plan
i'm going to try and make lace cookies
and what i'm gonna do is melt the
ingredients in a pan over the toaster
that's gotta work right and then i'm
going to drop them onto the sheet pan
and
cook them like that got white sugar
brown sugar butter and corn syrup a
pinch of salt
toaster on high
if i can pull this off i will be very
impressed so far it looks like a blob
oh okay okay this is this is looking
good wow
i'm gonna add a little bit of vanilla
this looks great it looks like a small
amount of batter but you only use like a
teaspoon per cookie and then they spread
and i'm just gonna wrap this foil
i wonder if i should take the tin foil
off
if i put these in the oven they would
kind of spread into like a perfect
circle but i think because the heat is
uneven you know it's coming out in slots
it's kind of formed these abstract
shapes i wonder if putting the sheet pan
on top
again to create that like oven
environment i would never recommend
doing this at home and i will also never
do this again i feel like my next course
will be a little more successful but at
this point who knows
[Music]
i'll be honest they don't look great
this is not what i envisioned
but
it's better than whatever happened with
the puff pastry so i'm gonna take it as
a win
okay moment of truth
they're so wrong is this the worst thing
i've ever made i hope the next course is
more successful
this has been a truly humbling
experience but i feel pretty optimistic
for my last course i'm gonna make shrimp
kebabs
how badly could it go i'm gonna be
pretty simple with the
seasonings all around just some salt
some paprika
some pepper and give it a toss i'm gonna
try with one shrimp first
[Music]
i don't know how dangerous this is it
feels pretty strange though oh but
there's some color on the shrimp it's
starting to get pink feeling better
feeling better wow it looks like it's
almost ready
one shrimp
looks pretty good i'm impressed
i have a sneaking suspicion
that i can do multiple shrimp in the
bags
i mean this is also good to know that it
takes only like one pop to get a shrimp
cool
well the shrimp cooks i'm gonna cut some
vegetables zucchini classic kabob
vegetable got some summer squash
seasonings are very simple here but
honestly
i feel like i'm too busy worrying about
you know if the toaster is gonna work i
mean it's like
totally working
these are great this is definitely the
most efficient thing i've done today i
mean
i'm knocking all the shrimp out in like
one pop
okay i'm gonna get some more bags put my
veggies in there and
we're moving right along
i'm gonna test
each one separately
vegetables are cooking
slowly they're more so steaming but
that's fine
not perfect but there's some hint of
color i feel pretty happy about that
these have a little color too these are
actually pretty cute
[Music]
toaster shrimp kebabs complete this
looks pretty delicious i'm gonna get my
other courses
and give everything a taste the moment
of truth
this was such an intense day i haven't
struggled this much since the microwave
i mean i had to make a totally new
dessert and it still doesn't look great
but i have to say i'm really happy about
the appetizer and main course like these
two look beautiful
i think my overall confidence is like a
seven
okay in my appetizer some of the chips
have gotten a little soggy so
okay that's a good looking chip
maybe i should try chip before before
dip
[Music]
oh
oh it's so bad
it just tastes burnt even though it
doesn't look burnt
it tastes burnt like all the way through
maybe the dip is gonna help me
wow
the dip is fantastic but i didn't use a
toaster to make the dip and even though
the dip is so great i can still taste
the burnt chip through it the taste of
these is like a zero maybe a one these
are bad these are so bad i really think
my kebabs look beautiful but let's see
how they taste
it's overcooked for sure if someone made
me this for dinner i wouldn't say
anything but i wouldn't really enjoy it
either
squash is fun
[Music]
oh god
the pepper has that burnt flavor too the
same as the potato although they do not
look burnt and frankly could use quite a
bit more time
taste-wise i would give this a three it
looks beautiful but this is not good
and now for my most embarrassing thing
i've ever made my cookies
not great tastes like
just tastes like burnt sugar and it's
kind of like adhering to my teeth i mean
i'd probably give those like a three
also edible
but do you want it
no
i think the toaster is the appliance
that has brought me down did i make
three courses with a toaster yes
are they good
not at all let me know in the comments
what you would make with a toaster i'll
see you next time
[Music]
[Applause]
you